Why are we here? Where do we come from? And
what will become of us in the future? There are so
many big questions out there that science, specifically geneticis, has
some amazing answers for. Now in this course so far, we've
just begun to understand the fundamentals that scientists and researchers
are using every day to try to answer these questions. If
you've made it this far, then you've been equipped with
the essential knowledge you need to go to the next step.
All you need to do is keep asking questions. And
fan the flame of curiousity and doubt. Genetics is the
central subject tying all the major facets of biology together.
And explaining the driving force behind evolution. Now while the
future of personalized medicine is about to come crashing down
on top of us whether we want it to or
not. My passion for genetics remains rooted in the simple
curiosity about the origin of life and the human condition.
I think Malcolm Potts and Roger Short summed it
up best in their biology textbook about the evolution of
human sexuality. At one extreme there are those who
like to think that a chicken is merely an egg's
way of making another egg. Or maybe, as Richard
Dawkins would have it, the soma is merely the product
of an ageless battle between selfish genes striving for mastery
and seeking propagation through succeeding generations. Our life on earth
has not been a series of discontinuous acts
of creation. But it is an unbroken thread
tying us all to our ancestors. And with
the potential of linking us to the innumerable
future generations. We are indeed trailing clouds of
glory. The glory of billions of years of
continuous evolution. We do not create life, we
have only the privilege of passing it on.